FEMALE SPEAKER: What
better way to end
this month on a strong
note than with a talk
by a lifetime advocate of women
leaders and entrepreneurs.
I've heard Denise speak last
October at the Grace Hopper
conference.
I loved her workshop on
leadership and communication,
and her actionable,
practical advice.
Here's one example.
She told us, here's what you
will stop doing-- pining,
whining, talking about weather,
traffic, and how busy you are.
Even in the coffee line, talk
about something meaningful,
she said.
It made me realize how often
we waste an opportunity
for a deep connection.
Denise has a long history of
advocacy for women leaders.
She started a nonprofit to
help women entrepreneurs.
She founded the
Thought Leadership Lab,
where she coaches executives,
entrepreneurs, and leaders
of Fortune 500 companies.
She co-founded
Springboard, a conference
for women entrepreneurs.
And last but not least,
she wrote a book,
"Ready to be a Thought Leader,"
which she will discuss today.
This talk is brought
to you in collaboration
with Talks at Google and
[INAUDIBLE] Women at Google.
Many thanks also
to those who helped
to make this event
happen, especially
to Regina [INAUDIBLE].
Without further ado, the
floor is yours, Denise.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DENISE BROSSEAU: I'm
delighted to be here actually
for three reasons.
First, because it's
Women's History Month,
and we're celebrating our
foremothers and our foresisters
who are really the people who
built the path that got us here
where we are today.
Secondly, because
I am really honored
to reconnect with all the folks
that I met at Grace Hopper.
How many of you guys go to
Grace Hopper conferences?
It's such a fun place where so
many wonderful women in tech
come together for the
first time, many of them.
And third, because we're
launching a women's community.
And honestly, my
whole career has
been about women's communities.
I belong to them, I start them.
I'm kind of a groupie.
So how did that begin?
I really wanted to share
some of that story.
The truth is, many years ago,
in the early part of my career,
I had the chance to take a
class on creativity in business.
And one of the things
that they asked us to do
was an exercise to
write our life mission.
Now honestly, I'd never
thought of doing such a thing.
I thought that's
what companies did.
And it took me weeks
and weeks of iterating
before I came up with
a mission statement
that I could live my life by.
And I want to share it with you.
My mission-- more women
leaders at the top
of every organization.
How many of you guys
believe that's a mission
worth accomplishing?
Yeah.
[CLAPPING]
So that's why I do
what I do, is I really
work to that mission statement.
And what I want to talk about
today is some of the paths
that I've taken to
get here, as well as
some of the techniques that I've
learned and some of the things
that I've learned from so many
other amazing people, my role
models, the people within
this community of technology
but also across the United
States and across the world.
So let's get started.
I want to start with a survey.
So take a minute and
look at all the choices.
I'm not sure what a
thought leader is.
I want to be a thought
leader, but I don't know how.
I've identified goals
that will help me build
a followership for my ideas.
Becoming a thought leader
is just not my top priority
right now.
Or, others already call
me a thought leader.
So let's have a
quick show of hands.
How many are A?
I'm not sure what a
thought leader is.
Yeah.
Admit it, right.
Not really entirely sure.
That word gets
bandied around a lot,
so we're going to kind of
define it, at least in the way
that I believe it
should be defined.
How many I want to
be a thought leader,
but I really don't know how?
OK, good, because we're going
to go through a lot of steps
today.
That's excellent.
OK.
I have identified goals
that help me already build
a followership for my ideas.
How many people are
in that category?
Great.
A couple of great folks here.
Becoming a thought leader is
not my top priority right now.
It's OK to admit that.
Maybe you have other
things on your to-do list.
But nobody in this
room has that.
Great.
All right.
And last, others already
call me a thought leader.
I've already been
defined that way.
Not quite yet.
All right, good.
Well that gives me a
sense of where we are,
because I want to spend some
time on both the definition
and the how-to steps,
because I think
it's really critical
to think about
what can we do to move on
that journey from leader
to thought leader.
What does it take.
But let's start with a
couple of examples of folks
that I admire, thought
leaders that I admire,
including the two
co-founders of wogrammer.
So these two women working
in the tech industry,
they kept getting the same
question over and over.
And it was always said
with a bit of trepidation,
like, what's it really
like to work in tech?
Sort of thinking
that maybe there
was going to be some bad answer
because of something they'd
read in the media.
And these two women felt
like that's not right.
Our careers are going well.
Women programmers have
great careers in technology,
and we want to share that story.
So they started
interviewing women.
First a few, then
dozens, then hundreds.
And now, they're out
speaking those stories
in front of lots
of big audiences.
They built a website where
they share their stories,
and now they're
working on a book.
To me, that is building a
followership for your ideas,
and changing the conversation.
Next is a guy Ron Finley.
He calls himself the
guerrilla gardener.
How many of you guys
have heard of Ron?
He's got a wonderful Ted
Talk, well worth listening to.
So he is an artist.
He lives in South
Central Los Angeles.
And one day, he built a
garden in his front yard.
He just planted a garden.
Now that's all well and
good, except for the city
owned that land.
And so within a few months after
his garden started to grow,
he got a letter, and it
said tear out your garden.
And he thought,
this is just wrong.
So he started a petition
and he got hundreds and then
thousands of signatures.
And he took it down to City
Hall, and he demanded a change.
And that change has actually
instituted an entire movement
around community gardens
in South Central, an access
to fresh food in a
place where it's just
strip mall after strip mall.
And he started to
spread those ideas
to other urban communities
so that homeless shelters are
building gardens, and they're
taking the abandoned lots
and turning them into
something useful.
And third is my client,
Von Ton-Quinlivan.
Von is passionate about
education and access
to great jobs for people from
disadvantaged communities
and from veteran-- and veterans
who return to the United States
after being away at war.
And she started a
program at PG&E,
a hundred-year-old
utility company,
to give access
for the first time
to those folks for
high-paying jobs,
and then spread that effort
across her entire industry
and started to spread it
across the United States.
And I'll be telling you
more about her story,
because she's actually
one of the reasons
that I wrote this book
was my work with her.
She really inspired me
to share what I learned
from my experience with her.
All right.
So what is a thought leader?
You've heard all of that.
Let me try to distill it.
It starts, I think,
by-- thought leaders
start by being change agents.
They've got something
that they're
doing that's different
than what's already
been done, or always been done.
And they inspire us
with that change.
They inspire a few
folks around them,
and then they recognize
that this innovation
is something worth spreading.
They understand they need
to replicate and scale that.
Because they themselves
can't do that alone,
they understand that they need
to start building followers
in order to build
sustainable change.
So thought leadership
is about starting
as a change agent,
which is why I think
this is such a powerful
conversation for folks
here at Google,
because so many of you
are creating
unbelievable innovations.
So now, how about
sharing those in a way
that those ideas
can be broadened,
those innovations can
become sustainable change.
When you think about
our foremothers that
are showcased on all
the walls around--
and those who are
not here in the room,
we've got posters of all
kinds of amazing women
who we're celebrating here
on Women's History Month.
They all replicated their
change beyond one small place
to something that
had a bigger impact.
Making an impact often
starts, though, locally.
It starts in one company,
one organization, one city,
one school, and then it
starts to grow from there
through the efforts of often one
or a small team of individuals.
And that starts to have
potentially the chance
to make a movement.
It is actually the art of
building a followership
for our ideas and for the
change that we have underway.
That, to me, is true
thought leadership.
It's not tweeting what
you had for lunch.
I know.
That used to be the old way.
Set up a Twitter account,
I'm a thought leader.
Like, no.
Not so much.
So I'm trying to reclaim this
word thought leader, because I
really do believe it's
something much bigger,
and something to really be proud
of when you get that moniker.
So let me tell
you a little story
about how I came to
this conversation.
The truth is, I'm an
accidental thought leader.
I had no plan to be
a thought leader.
I had no idea about
being a thought leader.
But I did work in the technology
industry for a number of years,
and co-founded an
organization called the Forum
for Women Entrepreneurs.
For those here in
Silicon Valley,
you may know it
now as Watermark.
But the organization
was originally
started around one idea,
and that number one
is where it started.
Less than 1% of
the venture capital
funding in the United States was
going to women entrepreneurs.
I don't know about you,
but I thought 50% was fair.
1% seemed astonishing.
And my co-founder-- that's her
there on the screen, Jennifer
Gilrobert-- she called me
up one day and she said,
we need to do
something about this.
And she was absolutely right.
And we created this organization
to offer three things--
education-- how do
you do this, how
do you do a venture-funded
scalable business in technology
and life science; how do
you access all the resource
providers-- the law firms,
the banks, accounting firms;
and then third, how
do you connect women
with others who are their role
models, those who have come
before, so that they can help
one another so that arm-in-arm
we can do this together.
So we created that organization.
I was doing it
full-time-- excuse me,
I was working
full-time, doing it
on the side, until I quit to
run the organization after five
years.
We had about 300 members,
and we started scaling
to other cities.
It was a lot of
work, a lot of fun.
And one day, the phone rang.
So imagine I'm just working away
at my own little organization,
I get a call from some group
called the National Women's
Business Council.
I'd never heard of them.
But they were working
at the national level
on similar issues of women
and access to capital.
And they called
and they said, we
want to host the first
venture conference
for women entrepreneurs.
You guys call them
Google demo days, right?
I attended the Google demo day
here a few week-- months ago
for women.
This was the precursor to that.
In fact, it was the
first venture conference
in the United States
for women entrepreneurs,
where we not only
put them on stage
but we coached them and got
them ready for prime time.
That eventually
became Springboard.
And that first conference
that we ran here in 2000,
we had 357 applicants.
We chose 27 women.
Within three months, 25 of
those companies got funded.
People told us that
was impossible.
They told us, first of all,
there were no women out there.
Who were we to think we
could put on a conference
of all women entrepreneurs.
But we proved them
wrong, and we went on
to scale that effort across
the United States and now
internationally.
But here's what
was so fascinating,
because doing that gave me this
whole different opportunity
to shape the conversation
about women's entrepreneurship.
I suddenly started getting
calls from the media.
I got a chance to go speak
at conferences nationally,
and even internationally.
I got a chance to serve on
committees and commissions
working on these issues.
I got a bully pulpit
about an issue
that I cared about deeply.
And I had no idea
what I was doing.
I mean, I'll be serious.
It's like-- I had to
quickly get media training.
I had to learn how
to tell our story
and tell our message
more broadly because I
had this chance.
So, great.
Springboard continues to scale.
We are all over, as
I said, the world.
We've helped companies like
Zipcar and Constant Contact.
That's the day we went to
NASDAQ and took Constant Contact
public on the NASDAQ.
It was an amazing high
for all of us involved.
Who would have ever thought
that that would happen?
And the organization now
continues to do its work
and, fast forward a few years,
I'm off doing other things
and I get a phone call from
this woman, Von Ton-Quinlivan,
who I mentioned earlier.
Von called me and she
said, so you know,
Denise, you became
a thought leader
in women's entrepreneurship.
I want to do that.
Honestly, I'm looking
at the phone going,
I was a thought leader?
I didn't know I was
a thought leader.
That wasn't a word
I'd use for myself.
Often, it's somebody else who
first gives you that moniker.
And she said, I want to do that.
And we sat down in her living
room and we wrote a plan.
It was a five-year
plan, from nobody
to well-recognized
thought leader.
And then she hired
me to help her do it.
And over the next three years,
she knocked it out of the park.
She went from creating a program
internally to her company
called Power Pathway, which was
a community college workforce
development program which
brought the community together,
the community colleges together,
and the company together
to actually train people
to get jobs at PG&E.
But then she spread that
across her industry.
She started serving on
committees and commissions,
testifying in front
of the US Senate,
recognized by the White
House, and then head-hunted
by the governor to do
the same work that she
did at PG&E across the
entire community college
system as the
vice-chancellor of workforce.
That was such a wake-up
call for both of us.
Honestly, I never knew that
you could do this with a plan.
And that's really
why I wrote my book.
I honestly wrote this
book for my younger self.
I mean, I wrote the
book that I wish
I'd had back when I first
had this sort of moment,
because there was
no book back then
and I want to give that same
seven-step process to all
the others who want
to follow in hers
and all these other women's
and men's footsteps.
So I want to talk about
some of the steps today,
and how do you do that.
Because thought
leadership gives you
a platform to change the world.
How many of us
would like to change
just a little part of the
world just a little bit, right?
That's probably why we're
working here, right?
This is a place that you
can get to change the world.
So why do you want to
be a thought leader?
I want to invite you, since
we're creating community,
to actually interact with
someone you haven't met before,
or someone who I call your
GC partner-- geographically
convenient.
I want you to answer this
question with someone.
You know, 30 seconds each.
And those who are on the phone
or sitting at their desk,
write it down.
Why do you want to
be a thought leader?
Here's some things
people tell me.
They tell me that they
want more influence.
They want more impact.
They want more income.
And they want to leave a legacy.
So which is it for you?
Or is it something
completely different
that I haven't even thought of?
So turn to your GC partner and
just share for a few seconds,
why do you want to do this.
What would make it
worthwhile for you.
Go ahead.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DENISE BROSSEAU: Shh.
It's always the hardest part.
When I ask a question like
this, people get so engaged.
But how many of you
guys, influence?
I really need more influence?
A few folks have that one up.
OK.
I like that.
OK, how about impact?
I want to have more impact?
The room goes up in flames here.
Yes, this is what I want.
How many would not mind
having a little more income?
OK.
All right.
Pretty much most of
the room on that one.
And how many would
like to leave a legacy?
Not just do a job, but leave
something behind that matters?
And then this is the one that
I found was so fascinating.
It's also career insurance.
We got health insurance
and life insurance,
what about career insurance?
People love to hire
thought leaders.
People love to work
for thought leaders.
People love to promote
thought leaders.
So this, to me,
having your ideas out
and a followership for
what you believe in,
this brings all kinds
of opportunities.
Honestly, when I hear
some of the people
that I know who've
come to Google,
they've come because they've
built a followership,
and they've gotten hired in
because of that following.
So, career insurance.
What a great reason
to do anything.
So how does it begin?
I believe it begins by
finding our passion.
Some of us, our passion is what
we get to do every single day.
Some of us, it's
in our community.
much more broad.
Some of us, sometimes
it's really tiny.
I just want to change one
thing in my kids' school.
But how do you figure that out?
How do you find
that intersection
of where you're going to play?
So I came up with this diagram.
We've all started it.
How many of you did
the Venn diagram
in fifth grade, fourth grade,
right, those three overlapping
circles?
I believe that this is the
key to figuring this out.
So it starts with where
you have credibility.
Often, it's where you
have some degrees,
you have some credentials.
Maybe you've won
an award, you're
part of a company
or a team that's
doing interesting
work in an area.
Or, it could be
based on the fact
that you've had people
whose lives you've changed.
Next circle is experience.
This could be the number
of years of experience,
or successful change agents.
You've made some
successful change.
That's experience.
You've managed a
major initiative.
Or even if you're
just starting out.
That's something that you
want to be out talking about.
And finally, commitment.
You are committed to
improving something.
You're committed to enabling
your team to be more effective.
There's lots of
different ways in which
this one comes into play.
But if we start there and then
find where the others overlap,
I find that that's where
people can most likely come up
with what I call their thought
leadership intersection point,
that place where all three
of the circles intersect.
This is critical, because we
can't be known for everything.
We can't be known for
being all over the place.
We have to find something,
a niche, one place
to play to be that go-to person.
So this is where it begins.
And I want to ask
you this question.
What is one thing you're
really passionate about?
I'm sure this room
is full of people
who are passionate about
a lot of amazing things.
So why don't you turn
back to your GC partner
and just share one thing,
in one sentence or less,
one thing you're
passionate about.
And it doesn't have to be
related to your day job.
I just want to give
you permission to be
thinking bigger than that.
OK.
One thing.
Share with the
person next to you.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DENISE BROSSEAU: Shh.
Here's the thing about
this conversation.
Remember during
Ella's introduction
and she said that
one thing she learned
is that we waste a
lot of time talking
about traffic and all the things
that we're too busy doing?
To me, if this was
the question we
were asking each other
standing in line for coffee,
wouldn't that shift
our entire day?
Wouldn't it shift
the entire community,
if this is what we talked
about all the time.
Whether it be with
our family members,
whether it be with our
friends, whether it
be with our colleagues.
So I talked to Sue-- just
going to pick on you here.
I'm guessing that one of the
things you're passionate about
is women's leadership.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DENISE BROSSEAU: Because Sue
leads the Women's Leadership
Network here within Google,
one of the few companies
I have ever heard
of that actually
has a full-time person devoted
to running their women's
network.
I think that's fabulous.
And to get to align what you're
passionate about with your day
job, that's pretty fabulous.
OK, what else?
Who else is passionate
about something
that they're willing to share?
Be brave now.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm quite
passionate about helping
other people be successful.
DENISE BROSSEAU: Helping
AUDIENCE: I'm not very
good at helping myself.
DENISE BROSSEAU: Oh, yes.
We're always really good
at the others, right.
She said that she's not very
good at helping herself,
but she's really good
at helping other people.
That's something to really
be passionate about.
And being able to see
them shine and see them
succeed, that's really
wonderful, isn't it?
What else?
One more idea.
One more something
somebody's passionate about.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: For me, it's
access to good food.
So there's a non-profit--
DENISE BROSSEAU:
So Autumn is really
passionate about great food.
I'm going to say this so
the people online can hear.
And she works with a
community organization that
goes into backyards,
picks the fruit
and re-distributes it so
that it doesn't go to waste
and people can get
out in the fresh air.
I'm ready to sign up.
So this, to me, is
where it begins, right?
If we can find that one
piece we're passionate about.
So I want you to start
thinking about this today.
If nothing came to
mind immediately,
this is where the
conversation starts.
The second is to
find your imperative.
I'm going to share--
Katie Orenstein is
one of the people I
interviewed for my book.
Katie is a former
journalist who is really
on a roll across
the United States
to create women empowered
to write op-eds.
Why is that?
What she realized is--
she did some research--
37% of the content contributed
to news outlets-- only 37%--
is women.
Only 15% of the editors
on Wikipedia are women.
Only 26% of the Sunday
morning news shows are women.
And she believed that
part of it was a challenge
with being able to
shape an argument,
being able to frame the
conversation in a way that
showcased new ideas without
discounting the old.
And so she created a program
called The Op-Ed Project--
theopedproject.org-- and
she goes around the country
offering op-ed seminars, one-day
sessions-- I've gone twice
over the five years that
I've known about it--
and spend a Saturday
and really learn
how to frame an
argument because that
is critical for everything,
whether it be getting up
in your own company to
articulate your ideas,
whether it be getting
on a big stage,
whether it be writing an op-ed
for the "New York Times,"
it takes shaping an argument
in a way, as I said,
that doesn't discount others.
And that's what she's
really passionate about,
because her belief is that if
we shape the conversations,
we shape regulations,
we shape policy,
and we shape the way we're
treated by the culture
that we live in.
That's her imperative.
So thinking to yourself,
what if for you.
Here's what I mean by that.
If we have a vision
of the future
that we can see-- what
if it looked like this--
and we can articulate
that for others,
that's when we can get
people to follow us.
So here's what I
recognized-- when
I started the Forum for
Women Entrepreneurs oh
so many years ago, we had
that conversation with people,
what if women had 50% of
the venture capital funding
in the United States?
I hate to say how
many years later it is
and we're somewhere
between 6% and 11%,
depending on what year it is.
We've been at this
for a long time.
The what if future
could be very far off.
But you want to imagine a
future and envision a future
and articulate a future, because
then others will get on board
and create that future with you.
That's what it takes.
We can't do any of this alone.
So that question of what
if, what is the better
future that you envision?
Write that one down as
something to go ahead
and think about when
you get home tonight.
Can I articulate it clearly?
Can I tell others what I
want to change in the world?
That's a really
important question
to be asking ourselves,
or asking our friends.
OK.
Another quick survey.
What, if anything,
is holding you back
from becoming a thought leader.
Now you know a little
bit about what it is.
We're starting to talk
about some of the steps,
and we're going to
talk about some more.
But I'm too busy,
I don't have time;
I don't have the appropriate
skill set, give me a few years;
I have some good ideas, but
sometimes I lack confidence;
or nothing, I'm on my way.
So let's see.
Show of hands, number
one, I'm too busy.
A couple.
Few.
OK.
Number two, I don't have
the appropriate skill set.
Not quite ready yet.
Give me a few years.
OK.
Number three, I
have some good ideas
but sometimes I lack confidence.
Yeah.
That one I see a lot.
Absolutely.
Or nothing, I'm on my way.
OK.
We've got a few folks in
the front of the room, who
sat front and center.
What does that tell you
about that front row?
Next time, you're going
to sit in the front row
because you'll be able
to say yes to that.
Here's what's been fascinating.
I've been around
the country talking
about these issues
and these ideas.
I've been around the
country to communities
of men, women, old, young, every
kind of background and culture,
and what I keep finding is the
same story, the same things
that are holding everyone back.
I'm beginning to wonder
who got the memo that
says it's OK, because nobody
I've met has got the memo.
It's either their company,
their boss, their culture,
their family, some sort of
religious norm, whatever.
There's so many reasons
why we don't do this.
There are so many things
that hold us back.
And I get that.
In fact, I added a whole
chapter in the center of my book
because I realize how important
this conversation of what
I call putting your
I-- the letter I--
put your I on the line.
So everyone I interviewed
for the book, I asked them,
what do you do?
How do you keep going?
How do you stay focused on
this as a priority for you?
And I put together what I
call the rules for resilience.
And I came up with
one image that I
think sort of tells the story.
And this is it.
Because how many days do
we get up in the morning
and we look in the mirror and
we see the lion and we think,
we can do anything,
we're invincible.
And how many times do
we get up in the morning
and we see the
little kitty that's
even smaller than ourselves,
because there's what I call--
or there's what my client
calls-- the itty bitty
shitty committee.
Right?
It's in our head.
It's very loud.
Anybody have one of those?
We all admit that we have one.
Those negative voices, they
tell us we can't do this,
we can't do this,
for whatever reason.
So how do we fire the itty
bitty shitty committee?
How do we move beyond those
conversations from our family
or our background that say don't
get too big for your britches,
or don't be a show-off,
or whatever it is
that we're telling ourselves?
So just think to
yourself and share
with the person next to you how
do you nurture your inner lion.
What's one thing you do?
Some people it's music.
Some people it's colleagues.
Some people it's getting
out and doing exercise.
But just share with
the person next to you
what's one thing you do
to build your courage,
to feel invincible, to feel
like anything is possible?
OK.
Match up with somebody.
What is one thing?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DENISE BROSSEAU: Shh.
Can I hear just a few folks?
Who has something?
Let's hear those little secrets.
What is it that
you do to nurture
that sense of confidence?
What's a couple of things?
There must be some great
ideas in this room.
I believe it.
AUDIENCE: Coming to this talk.
DENISE BROSSEAU:
Coming to this talk.
Thank you.
That's very sweet, Ella.
And how many of you
watch Ted Talks?
I really-- I love to watch
Ted Talks because they inspire
me to think, here's a
person who came from nobody,
came from nowhere, and
look at this amazing thing
that they're doing.
What else are you trying?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
suggestion.
Just tell yourself
you can do it.
DENISE BROSSEAU: Tell yourself.
The positive voice instead
of the negative voice.
So it's that mantra, that
repeating, I can do anything.
I am amazing.
Wouldn't that be a wonderful
thing to wake up to.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Reminding
yourself of [INAUDIBLE].
DENISE BROSSEAU: Yes.
Remind yourself the past.
What's the journey
I've already been on?
What have I already overcome
to get where I am today?
Because if I could do
that, I can do anything.
That's what's so fun about
the Grace Hopper conference.
You know, I get this room of
600 women, and I ask them,
how many of them came from
another part of the world.
And, like, 80% of
them raise their hand.
How many of you
are doing business
in a language that's
not your first language?
You know, 75%.
And I think, you can do that?
The rest of this is easy.
Honestly.
That feels impossible to me.
And yet, so many
people have done that.
So you're right, reminding
ourselves of where we've been
and what we've already overcome.
So I want you to think
about your own practices.
And actually maybe
document them,
because there's days
when you kind of need
to remind yourself.
It's one of those little
kitty days, what can I
do today to actually
bring myself back
to feeling confident.
That's an important
list to have handy.
Put it on your smartphone
so that you have that ready.
OK.
Let's go on to step four
here, because this was really
the biggest awakening, the
biggest learning, for me
when I was doing this book.
I'm a start-up girl.
I started my first
company when I was 26.
I love the start-up phase.
I join all kinds of start-ups.
I insisted on being
employee 13 or less,
because I love that first part,
right, where there's nothing.
It's all to get figured out.
And then I started
to talk to people
who really were thought
leaders in the world,
and what I learned was that
this was the essential step.
You have to codify what
you've done so others
can follow in your footsteps.
So one of the
people I interviewed
is actually someone
here at Google.
How many of you know Avinash?
Right?
So Avinash started
his career at Intuit.
He started working for the
first time with search engine
optimization tools, and
he realized that they
were really hard to implement.
It was hard to get his company
on board with the kinds
of things he needed to do.
So he spoke at a
conference one day,
and he started telling
these experiences.
And two guys came up to him
at the end, and they said,
you should write a blog on that.
And when we were talking, when
I interviewed him on the phone,
he said, there were
already thousands of blogs.
Who was I to blog?
So he tried a test.
He just sent it out
to maybe 10 or 12
or 13 different
colleagues, and his wife,
to see what people thought.
Did he have anything to say?
And he came up with a set
of principles, one of which
really resonated with me.
And that is, uncomplexify.
Now, I know this a made-up word.
But what he-- the
reason that he said
this is that he recognized that
the kinds of things that you
guys are dealing
with in technology,
or people in health care or
whatever field they're in,
they are complicated.
And we're not talking
about dumbing down,
we're talking about simplifying.
Getting rid of the jargon,
getting rid of the acronyms.
I worked at Motorola.
I understand the
world of acronyms.
But that's not how others
can follow your path.
So he started blogging
and, over time, he
got a call from
somebody at Wiley
and they said, what if we
put your blogs into a book?
And then he wrote a second book
with more blog posts in it.
Today, he has blog
followers around the world
and, of course, followers on
social media from everywhere.
But he tells me
that the one thing
he's most excited about from his
experience is the love letters.
He gets love letters
from all over the world.
He said he gets love
letters from young people
when they're first
stepping into their career,
thank you so much for
giving me the path that I
can follow for my career.
Another, a senior
executive at a big company,
a global company,
saying thank you
for being able to distill
that, because I was really
having trouble understanding
how I could get my team
to get on board with that.
Uncomplexify.
It's a really key point.
Another part of this
codify your lessons learned
is about models, frameworks.
So my friend Robin Chase, the
CEO and founder of Zipcar,
she just came out with a new
book called "Peers, Inc."
And she created this cool model.
I can't get into
the whole details,
but these are the
kinds of things
that people who want to go
from leader to thought leader
start to think about.
It's showing the pathway.
It's showing the path.
How did I get here?
What are the things
I believe in?
What's my credo?
What's the framework?
How can I do this?
So when I was doing my
own book, of course--
and it was all
about frameworks--
I had to go out and hire
somebody to create me
a framework, because
I had no idea,
just to articulate
my seven steps.
We're covering a
few of these today.
And this is available
on my website,
but this is, to me, the
steps that it takes.
You're not going to always
start in the same place.
But that's part of what
we're talking about.
You want to articulate what
are the steps that others
can take to move forward.
And then we're going to talk
about being discoverable.
Being discoverable
is pretty important.
And what was so fun when
I was preparing this talk
was to see the
discoverable behavior
of some of your colleagues.
So, being discoverable could
be having a great LinkedIn
profile.
How many have a great
LinkedIn profile?
About a third of the room, OK.
Maybe half on a good day.
OK.
How many have put themselves
forward for an award?
One.
Two.
So I just want to say, I
got nominated for an award.
An organization contacted
me and they said, could you
complete this form.
And so I completed the
form and I sent it back,
because I thought getting an
award would be kind of fun.
And the woman wrote back and
she said, that was remarkable.
And I said, what do you mean?
She said, a third of the
people don't open the e-mail
past the first target
line, and no one
has ever gotten the
form back in 24 hours.
I didn't think I
was that strange,
but this is what
I'm talking about.
If we don't put
ourselves forward
or co-nominate
someone else, we're
not going to be
discoverable for our ideas.
So here's a few people
within your community
who are-- this is my
friend Joyce Dickerson,
who's out of town or would
have been here today.
She's from the Global Data
Center on Sustainability.
Used to be at Stanford.
And she was talking
at an online forum
about hosting a summit on
how green is the internet.
It's a great little video.
I definitely recommend
you go watch it,
because she talks about
how that team has really
done thought leadership around
these ideas of sustainability.
And then I found
our very own Vidya,
who will be speaking
on the panel, who
was doing a fun little
video about how to unleash
the power of Chrome kiosk apps.
And I found Joanna Smith
from the Android team
who was on Medium telling
people about how--
developers about how
to use the Google tools
to create great interfaces.
And I found internationally your
Google Nigeria country manager,
who was hosting
a wonderful panel
program similar to
this showcasing women
leaders in her country,
and being able to share
that with the Google community.
So this is another
question I want
to leave you to think about.
How will you be more
discoverable this year?
What is one thing you can do
to get your ideas out there?
I'm going to give you three
possible things that you
wouldn't have thought about in
how to answer this question,
starting here with convening.
So one of the powerful
ways that Von really
changed things in
her industry is she
convened a consortium
across her industry.
How did we do that?
The idea was to find all
the people with her same job
title in other companies
in the utility industry
and invite them to join her
in a quarterly gathering.
She found a host-- excuse
me, a head of the group,
and she was the co-head.
The head of the group
was a guy that was
well-respected and well-known.
She was completely
unknown in the community.
So as the co-chair
of the consortium,
she had a chance
to draft the agenda
to make sure her agenda got
discussed at every meeting.
Convening is a very powerful
strategy for thought leaders,
bringing people together
to share best practices
but also sharing your own.
Sharing what you're
struggling with
and learning from other people,
but also teaching other people.
Second strategy.
I couldn't go without
talking about Sheryl.
When people ask-- and
outside the Bay Area,
when I ask people what's one
thought leader they think of,
this is the first person
that comes to mind.
But what I think is unique
about what she's done,
she went from a talk to a
book to building a community,
empowering people to start
their own communities.
So think about
yourselves this year.
She has actually
created this possibility
for women who are really excited
and passionate about women's
leadership to create
Google-- excuse
me, create Lean In circles.
How many of them are
within Google right now?
How many of you guys have been
to a-- you have some here,
right?
The one in Palo Alto I think
is like 700 people now.
I got to speak for them
a couple years ago.
I was like, 700 people.
They don't all come.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DENISE BROSSEAU: OK.
It was a little scary.
But maybe 50 or 60
come to each session,
and we have a chance to discuss
the things that Sheryl's really
advocating about how to lean in.
And last, I want to
have a little exercise
here on my third strategy,
which I call amplify.
And I want to actually
get you all out
of your chairs for a few
minutes and playing with me.
So let me explain how
this is going to work.
You're all going to match
up in groups of three,
and you're going to each
have a separate role.
Role number one is
the interviewer.
And the interviewer
has a microphone.
You see my microphone, right?
And you're going to
interview the other person.
You're always going to say
the same question-- tell
me one thing about yourself
that you really like.
Or what's your
superpower, if you prefer.
The second person
is the interviewee,
and they were going to
answer the question.
The third person
is the amplifier.
Let me show a little bit
about how that might work.
So let's say that the person
says, I'm really brave.
That the attribute I'm
most proud of about myself.
So how might you amplify that?
So I'm going to make this up.
So let's say Sue says,
I'm really brave.
Because you're really
brave, Sue, aren't you?
Sue is not just brave, Sue
is the bravest woman I know.
She climbed Annapurna last year.
She goes and jumps
out of airplanes.
Not only that, but
she organizes events
that bring together thousands
of women to change the world.
She's brave every
day for her daughter.
day for her team.
Now, I've only met
Sue for five minutes.
I have no idea if she
does any of those things.
You're making it up.
This is for fun, OK?
And how long do you go?
How long does this last?
Go as long as you
can plus 20 seconds.
This is supposed to take you
out of your comfort zone.
And I'll explain why
you're doing this.
But after the
first person, we're
going to go on to the
second and then the third.
You've got maybe just a
few minutes to do this,
because I want to leave some
time for questions at the end.
But everybody rotates,
everybody plays each role.
And the last thing is, when
I ask you for one superpower
or attribute, I do not
mean your cute shoes
or your cool glasses.
This means an attribute,
something that you
do that you're really proud of.
And the first thing
that came to mind
is not the one you
dismiss right now.
That was the
committee showing up.
No.
Whatever you thought, I'm
proud of this attribute,
that's the one you say.
All right?
Everybody up.
Match into threes.
Nobody gets to not play.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DENISE BROSSEAU: All right,
so here's my question.
How many of you
like the people that
were in your group
a whole lot better
than you did a few minutes ago?
What is that about?
AUDIENCE: Because they're
complimenting you.
DENISE BROSSEAU: Right?
They just said nice
things about you.
How much of this
behavior is going on
in our day-to-day lives?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DENISE BROSSEAU: I'm kind of on
a roll around as many audience
as I can to get more of
this amplifying behavior.
Not everyone is going to be
on the front of the stage.
the thought leader tomorrow.
But all of us can amplify.
All of us can
amplify each other.
And this kind of behavior
just is so reinforcing.
It gets us to want to come
to work in the morning
if somebody's actually
paying attention.
Now by the way, those people
were making that stuff up.
What if somebody was
amplifying something
you were actually doing?
Something you're
actually good at?
That, to me, is
the counterbalance
to the committee.
It's the idea that
if our culture--
we were talking
during the break about
how often, if we come
from another place, that's
a place that was told-- we
were told, that's not-- you
don't put yourself forward.
So we need others
sometimes to find
that little secret passion,
that little expertise that we
see but we discount.
And we want people to
be amplifying that,
so you can be amplifying
that for each other.
That's something I really
wish for your community,
to have much more of the--
like, nominate someone
else for an award.
Put someone else forward
to be on a panel,
or be on a panel with
someone for the first time
if they've never done it.
Help somebody to think through
what they're passionate about.
I was talking during
the break, as well,
about how-- people said,
well, how do I do this?
I don't know what
my-- I don't know
how to do that
[INAUDIBLE] exercise.
So I will share with
you some worksheets
that I have, but let me
just cover this last couple
questions.
And the first, this is
really the ultimate question.
How will you support
each other this year.
How could you create
little communities
of folks who want to take the
first steps on the thought
leadership path?
How could you potentially
use a Lean In Circle
model to come together on a
weekly, monthly, or quarterly
basis to actually
amplify one another
and invite and empower
each other to move forward
in this conversation?
Because to me, thought
leadership is not
about being known,
it is about being
known for making a difference.
So my invitation
every time I give
this talk is to say, what
do you want to be known for?
That's such a great question
to be asking ourselves.
And we're so busy
with our to-do list,
we often forget to ask it.
So I will take some questions,
but if you want to reach me,
this is how you can find me.
I want to invite you to be
more discoverable this year.
I want you to help other
team members and colleagues
to be more discoverable.
And if I can help
you or your team
to be more influential, to
make that journey from leader
to thought leader,
this is what I do.
I get to work with amazing
people, many of them
women leaders, and their
teams who are really
making that journey and helping
them to think through what
are all the strategies
they can use, how can they
be more effective and
be more efficient at it.
And if you send me a
note to denise@thoughtle
adershiplab.com--
denise@thoughtle
adershiplab.com-- I will send
you a secret page on my website
which has a whole set
of worksheets which
go with the book, because I
really believe that there is
some very basic steps
that you can take,
but sometimes taking them
from just reading a book
can feel overwhelming.
The book is written as
a seven-step process,
with a ton of resources and
questions to ask yourself,
but the worksheets are
sort of an adjunct to that.
All right, so, happy to
take a few questions.
I know we're running
up against time,
but who has a question for me?
How long does it take.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, how long it
takes to from [INAUDIBLE]--
DENISE BROSSEAU: From
leader to thought leader.
Yeah, I wish I could
say, oh, about a week.
All done.
Honestly, everybody takes
a little different path,
and everybody takes a
little different timeline.
For me, it was really
in a year because it was
kind of I was the go-to girl.
I was one of three or four
people in the United States
who knew anything about a topic
in the middle of the dot.com
craze, and it was the
hot topic and everybody
wanted someone to talk to.
We had an organization, we
were doing interesting things,
we were out showcasing
women entrepreneurs.
And so that's why I got this
opportunity and really kind of,
over the next year
after the conference,
just kind of went everywhere.
Others of my clients have taken
definitely longer than that.
You know, for Von, it was
three years from beginning
to getting her head hunted to
the job at the chancellor's
office.
From absolute zero-- a brand-new
job, no team, no resources,
nothing-- to being head-hunted.
That was three years.
So everybody's different.
And by the way, it
doesn't really-- to me,
it's not so much about the time
it takes, but the impact you
have along the way.
So much of this is
about figuring out
how am I going to
measure my success.
Am I measuring it
by my followership?
Am I measuring it by
people adopting my ideas?
Am I measuring it
by just feeling
more career satisfaction,
which you mentioned.
Do I just feel more like
I'm leaving that legacy
that I want to leave.
That kind of measurement
stick is a little
different than just a timeline.
AUDIENCE: I imagine to be
a really good and diligent
thought leader
that you have to be
able to take a lot of bumps
and bruises along the way,
and a lot of resilience and
have a lot of perseverance.
So I'm just interested
to hear-- that, to me, I
feel like is sometimes
where I hesitate,
like do I want to take all
the bumps and bruises coming.
DENISE BROSSEAU: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: So I'm curious
to know your approach when
those come on the road.
DENISE BROSSEAU:
Yeah, there's arrows.
There are definitely
arrows that come our way.
But here's the thing that's
so fascinating to me.
Usually, in our mind, they're
way bigger than the actuality.
All the different people that
I've worked with over the eight
years I've been doing this
work, there have been arrows,
I'm not going to kid you.
But usually, we imagine
them to be way bigger,
and we stop ourselves because
we think that's going to happen.
And yet, what we
find is, when we
do we hit a bump
in the road-- I'm
not saying we don't have
them, I have one client
who put out a post that really
wasn't well-researched and got
some real pushback on you don't
have the facts-- but being
able to clarify and build--
re-build the credentials
after that and the credibility
after that by owning it up.
The truth is like anything.
Innovation is about
making mistakes.
bumps in the road
and overcoming those bumps.
And by having a community or
having someone else next to you
to lean on, I highly
recommend that.
You know, that definitely helps.
And then lastly, I
would say that there's
this great quote by a guy
named Hank Lieber that I put
in the book, and he
talks about there really
is no such thing as failure.
He says, failure is if you keep
doing the same mistake over
and over and over.
Otherwise, it's just learning.
And we all want to keep
learning, so keep going.
Which I think is just a very
powerful reframe of this.
Yes, people are
going to bump into me
and they're going to
question me and doubt me.
But the more I can keep
going and learning from that,
the stronger I get.
As one of the women I
interviewed in the book said,
you have to get ready for
when you're not ready.
Because we're not ready, right?
We weren't ready for the job
we have right now, were you?
Right?
We're not.
But picking ourselves up,
brushing ourselves off,
and keep going.
But thank you all for
being here and thank you
for playing with me today.
[APPLAUSE]
I really appreciate it.